i'm having so much fun mary kate olsen
is single
and in no hurry to mingle the fashion
designer and her hubby olivier sarkozy
split in may after five years of
marriage
now a source tells et that the 34 year
old is in no rush to start dating again
quote the ink's not even dry good point
it's only been three months people you
know sometimes it takes a while to
reset anyway the source adds that mary
kate will
no doubt find love again it's just not a
priority at the moment
quote there is no shortage of things in
her life that bring her joy right now
according to e.t source mary kate has
been making it a point to stay
occupied with work mary kate is
naturally a homebody
but lately she's been pushing herself to
get out and keep busy
she's also been spending time with her
friends hanging out in the hamptons
inviting people over to her rental and
dining out at her favorite restaurants
uh sounds pretty nice to me
mary kate and olivier tied the knot in
2015
after three years of dating and mary
kate officially filed for divorce in new
york in may
after the state lifted its moratorium on
non-essential and non-emergency court
filings
at the time a source told et that the
two were simply
in different places in their lives
you